well last night we showed you the video
and it was nauseating of senior World
Health Organization official Bruce
Aylward a Canadian refusing to answer
questions about Taiwan and how it was
dealing with coronavirus in fact Howard
wouldn't even acknowledge the question
or acknowledge the existence of Taiwan
it was repulsive but it wasn't
surprising Howard was just following
directions from the very top Ted Rose ad
gnam he's the director general of the
World Health Organization got his job
with Chinese support after he covered up
cholera outbreaks in his home country a
perfect man to lead the World Health
Organization and he has subsequently set
the standard for corruption there here
he is in January watch this the Chinese
government is to be congratulated for
the extraordinary measures it has taken
to contain the outbreak the speed with
which China detected the outbreak
isolated the virus sequenced the genome
and shared it with whu-oh and the world
are very impressive
China is actually setting a new standard
for outbreak response and it's not an
exaggeration that's the top public
health official in the world and
everything you just heard him say there
was a lie a recent 60 minutes piece from
Australia a piece our media are not
playing shows just how deep the lies go
in fact there was nothing speedy about
how China detected the outbreak and then
warned the world indeed they did the
exact opposite from the very beginning
throughout December it was spreading and
we now know it was spreading
human-to-human but the official line of
the Chinese government was that this was
all related to an animal market and once
they closed the market it would all go
away did they no differently at that
time absolutely because they were seeing
cases coming into the hospitals that had
nothing whatsoever to do with that
animal market so the World Health
Organization's leadership tells you that
China quote set the standard
for the outbreak - the response
apparently that standard includes
disappearing doctors who tell the truth
about it as China now tries to rewrite
history and claim it was transparent all
along a final nail in the coffin of
their lie just two weeks ago the head of
emergency at Wuhan central hospital dr.
I fen also went public saying
authorities had stopped her and her
colleagues from warning the world she
has now disappeared whereabouts unknown
again why is it left to Australian media
to produce a piece like this the truth
is as 16 minutes Australia explains
instead of worrying about these
developments in early February the
director of the World Health
Organization was - lecturing the public
that using terms like Wuhan virus was
racist having a name matters to prevent
the use of other names that can be
inaccurate or stigmatizing you might
think that a world health organization a
group that got fifty eight million of
your tax dollars last year might care
that a government arrests doctors and
lies about deadly new diseases but no
like so many other organizations they
are lapdogs for the powerful and that
means the real job is sucking up to the
Chinese government